in the real world we communicate like
this with facial expressions and spoken
words in the messaging world we rely on
tiny text bubbles and the occasional
emoji we've lost that warmth that human
touch until now hello I'm a bit moji
what the heck is that
it's your personal emoji or sticker in
the Android or iPhone bitmoji app you
customize a digital cartoon to look like
yourself then you pick from various
scenes and expressions and you send it
to a friend in a message see much more
expressive they are than emojis and
plain text by the way the emojis aren't
actually animated like me oh you think
this is just for 12 year olds no
according to bitmoji co-founder Bob
Blackman whole families use bitmoji to
communicate now teens parents
grandparents everyone making a bitmoji
like me is free but it's all part of a
booming digital sticker business line a
popular messaging app in Japan says it
makes more than twenty million dollars a
month from sticker sales a month the
sticker buying trend has spread around
the world and now with Apple's new
message app store it's exploding there
are stickers for sale from independent
makers and artists it's actually so easy
to make one for Apple's new messaging
store
I made one on my own naturally of my dog
and then there are the celebrity
stickers like Kim Kardashian's Kim og $2
buys you all sorts of stickers some not
suitable for work and she keeps
releasing more packs for one dollar a
piece according to sensor tower Kim og
is set to make more than a million
dollars in revenue this year big grands
Burger King Starbucks Dunkin Donuts all
offer their own sticker packs they're
free so you'll do their advertising for
them and yes your bit mode you can
appear in movie and TV themes offered
and sponsored packs yes little cartoons
are the mobile tech industry's latest
cash cow
but they're also a lot of fun and can
help you express yourself better by